my children and grandchildren but here
we are
and i honestly have decided
that my friends across the aisle
must not be paying very much attention
to what is going on back home
because in tennessee the people back
home are very frustrated
with them they seem out of touch
they seem to not care
they don't seem to be interested in
taking care of people
with needs that have been adversely
impacted by kovid
they seem to be more interested in
taking care of themselves
this year really did not have to end
this way as i said our friends across
the aisle
could have addressed this back in the
summer in july
the minority leader and his colleagues
in the house
immediately rejected our heels
act proposal in favor of speaker
pelosi's mega trillion dollars
three trillion dollar wish list
that they had dubbed the heroes act you
know they always
give such nice sounding names
to thing who could be against this
but they rejected the hills act proposal
that was
targeted specific relief
and went with the heroes act it was a
very partisan bill it contained
provisions
that had nothing to do with coveted
relief
and that the house and the senate
democrats
knew were going to be stumbling blocks
their bill was filled with things
nothing
to do with taking care of people but oh
they had it full of poison pills
why they wanted to make certain that
relief didn't come
they wanted to make certain that they
could run this out
get it past the election and then we
find
out from speaker pelosi herself
and from some of the other democrats
that are in leadership
why did they do this oh politics it
helped them
with the election they thought
so they used
they used people as pawns
now that heroes act that they continue
to like
to talk about it would have undermined
state voter id requirements
and it gave the green light to some
ballot harvesting schemes
isn't it interesting what are we talking
about
what are tennesseans talking about so
much
yep you got it ballots
elections some of the harvesting
some of the tricks now those items
they had in the heroes act they didn't
have anything
to do with targeted relief
but you know what they were willing to
play these games
and to withhold that relief why
they thought that it helped them
in winning an election so that was all
back in july
then comes september 10th
the democrats again blocked forward
motion on another targeted bill
throwing a procedural hurdle in between
the american people
and desperately needed relief
i got by with it in july so september
rolls along it's about time
for people to start getting ballots
mailing
in ballots what do they do
they decide to mess with it again
to play politics to use people as
pawns they lowered the bar even further
on october 21st throwing away
500 billion dollars in targeted relief
they all voted no in an attempt to tear
our focus away from another round of
funding
for small businesses support for schools
and more money for coveted 19
testing now think about this
time and again they say
oh we've got to have more ppp we have to
have
more unemployment insurance we have to
have more money for
vaccines we have to have more money for
testing
we have to have more money for getting
schools open
but they vote no they have turned
their back on the american
people repeatedly they did it in july
they did it in september they did it in
october they
have turned their back
think about what a plus up of
unemployment would have done for a
family
have they decided to vote yes and work
with us
in july
that would have been a lot of money
if they had that plus up every single
week through august september october
november december
now i mentioned the october 21st
vote one day earlier
on october 20th democrats had blocked
senate action to
extend the ppp
that is all of our small businesses and
yes indeed
they are hurting
we are hearing from them on the phone
through email they are begging
for relief but the minority leader threw
another possibility of compromise
out the window by again
insisting that democrats would accept
the full
heroes act or nothing
isn't that amazing that's what small
businesses have gotten
is nothing
because my colleagues
across the aisle have basically said
give us everything we want
or we'll just vote no we'll just leave
people
suffering so it's not republicans
that have voted no republicans have
consistently tried to help
people and my friends across the aisle
are consistently trying to help
themselves
and use people as pawns
at the beginning of this month the
minority leader took to the floor
again he rejected targeted
relief again
and he demanded that republicans come to
the table well we've been at the table
they're the ones that reject proposal
after proposal
don't want to move forward on things
where there is agreement
want to hold out
they have not been paying attention to
what is going
on outside the four walls of this
chamber
and they continue to say we have to have
money
to bail out cities and states
only they call it aid to cities and
states but it's
bailouts for these big blue cities
and states that were having problems
long before lockdowns came along
and they have really made an
uncomfortable spot for themselves
because of irresponsible
spending policies and
i know that tennesseans
do not want to see their tax dollars
going
to bail out people who have chosen to
waste
their taxpayers dollars and i
can't help but wonder how much longer
the democrats are going to allow
industries and small businesses and
individuals to twist in the wind
because they feel like this is a great
time
to push their socialist agenda
get us on that fast track oh that's what
they would like to do
and still and you know
mr president we had a hearing this week
in commerce committee
and had some of the venues in the live
entertainment industry
come before us people that
tend to these stages when the curtains
go up people that are
working backstage
we heard from michael strickland
out of knoxville whose company bandit
lights
they like these stages help these shows
look great and you've got millions of
people that are in these support
industries we heard from the motor coach
industry we have heard from some of
these smaller
venues they are totally
shut down they were totally
shut down when the country went
into lockdowns they were
the first to be totally closed
and they're going to be the last to
reopen
these are people joined by small
business retailers and
restaurants that can't open their doors
and small business manufacturers
that have got to wait for the supply
chain to kick
back up so that they can
re-open their production lines
and they are saying
we need the help they're asking us
who is blocking it who is holding
out and we tell them repeatedly
they could have had relief
in july or they could have had it back
in september
or a couple of times in october
or november or
earlier in december
and it is not republicans
that have blocked that relief
time and again the democrats have
blocked republican
proposals to send funding where
it is needed most they've rejected
every single lifeline that we have tried
to throw i think it's become clear
that the democrats in washington dc
never really saw getting assistance
to the unemployed getting
help to small businesses as
a priority instead they looked at this
they saw a crisis they said well
this is an opportunity let's not let
this crisis go to waste
they have used it so
that they can push their message their
agenda
do what the federal government says or
we will let you drown
so
they know that their bills weren't
meant to act as
help maybe they were
meant to be a push
for their leftist agenda
they know that the emergency financial
provisions of the cares act were never
meant to replace
private markets or be used as a
mechanism to bail out state and local
governments
but you know what they're going to push
to try to make it so to further
a leftist agenda crisis management
is no substitute for fiscal policy
so i would say to
our friends on the left
these tactics have failed
it is time to stop using the american
people
as pawns read your mail
listen to the phones people
want targeted relief
that will help them to get to recovery
i yield the floor
i yelled the floor
mr president senator for pennsylvania
uh thank you mr president i want to
address the ongoing debate
over the content of
a relief bill that i think we've made a
lot of progress
on and i am hopeful that we can get
finished
many of our colleagues have been down
here and have reminded all of us quite
rightly
of the terrible difficulties that many
americans are facing
we are not in a full-blown financial
crisis anymore
but we're experiencing a lot of economic
hardship it tends to be concentrated in
certain sectors and industries
and we have a full-blown healthcare
crisis so it's a very very serious
moment and it demands
a response i am hoping we can get that
done as soon as possible
and i want to discuss one of the terms
that
i have advocated for in this legislation
the terms i've advocated for have been
mischaracterized including by the senate
minority leader
and others and so i want to set the
record straight
on what this is all about and why i
think this is so important
and to do that i think it's worth
remembering
what brought us to this point back in
march
when the coronavirus was first ripping
across america and wreaking so much
havoc
the response in many many places was a
complete economic shutdown a complete
prohibition
against doing business against going to
work against earning a lifetime
i'm earning a livelihood and i
understand why that was done
that we were in a health care crisis and
that was the response that was believed
to be most likely to prevent
an overwhelming of our health care
capabilities that would have been
absolutely horrific and so we had this
economic disaster and what we discovered
in march
was this shutdown brought us to the
brink of a financial
crisis as well if you think about the
financial markets where people are
providing capital to businesses and
municipalities and individual they only
do that if there is some confidence
that they know at least generally
speaking what the future looks like
we've never seen anything like the
government shutting down
our economy before and so not really
shockingly
the financial markets were on the verge
of completely freezing up
shutting down and preventing even the
most basic functioning
of our economy i mean businesses
might we might well have gotten to the
point where a business couldn't go to
its bank and borrow the money it needs
to make payroll on friday
or they they couldn't issue the bond
that they need to do to pay off another
bond that's coming due and so that would
put them in default and force them into
bankruptcy and require them to lay
everyone off
i mean the knock on effects would have
been devastating
had our financial system completely
frozen up
and mr president it was on the verge
some would say it was actually in the
process
of freezing up and so that's why the
treasury secretary and the federal
reserve board governor came to congress
and said look we need
some extraordinary unprecedented new
facilities that we can stand up very
very quickly
and we can use them to be a backstop to
restore
confidence and to enable
private credit to start flowing again
so that this economic
recession that we're certainly going to
go through back in march it was clear
that was going to happen
but it was not clear that we had to
suffer through
a financial crisis that would create a
depression that was something we thought
maybe we can avoid so these facilities
were set up as i say to restore the
normal functioning of private lending
and private capital markets
not to replace those markets not to pick
winners and losers and decide well who
gets
credit and who doesn't depending on
whether we like their business
not to subsidize not to say well look
you know let's just
give cut rate loans to the people we
like to give them to none of that was
the intention none of that was the
purpose the purpose was to ensure
that creditworthy borrowers could access
credit
through the normal channels that was it
that was the purpose
of what has been what's widely described
as the 13
3 lending facilities there were several
of these facilities
that was the intention for these
facilities and guess what
they worked they worked amazingly well
remarkably well within days certainly
weeks
markets were again functioning credit
was flowing and matter of fact
within a matter of months we were
credit was flowing at an all-time record
pace corporate bond issuance hit an
all-time record high
across the credit quality spectrum
municipal bond issues
all-time record high borrowers
businesses that wanted to
keep their workers and continue to
survive until we got past this
covid crisis that they were able to draw
down lines of credit from their banks
it worked the creation of these
facilities
gave the confidence to our financial
markets that restored the normal
functioning of
those markets it was really quite
extraordinary now that that doesn't mean
that
the economy got perfect after that
certainly not economy is not perfect
today
but it meant that a recovery would be
possible
we'd be able to function we'd be able to
begin to pick up the pieces of a closed
economy
and sure enough we've made tremendous
progress
more than half of all the people who
lost their jobs are back at work
so that's not anywhere near where we
need to end up
but we're on the right track in part
because these facilities did exactly
what they were designed to do
now what is my language in this bill
does what my language does
is it puts an end to these three
programs
that did their job they functioned they
restored the
private credit markets and so they don't
need to
continue
what are these three programs there's a
corporate bond credit facility
there's a main street lending program
and there's a municipal lending program
actually they were hardly used at all so
quickly
did the normal private credit markets
resume
their normal functioning that very few
borrowers
took advantages in fact i'm pretty sure
in the corporate
market i should say the corporate credit
facility that was set up under these 133
facilities
i don't think anything was done at all
the main street lending it was very
little
municipal lending there were two
borrowers that's it
these are the programs that were funded
by the cares act
were set up at the time of the cares act
for this narrow specific purpose
and now they've achieved their purpose
by the way there's lots of other
programs
that have been set up over time some
were set up recently
that my legislation doesn't touch in any
way shape form or fashion the commercial
paper funding facility
unaffected money market fund liquidity
uh provision unaffected paycheck
protection program
primary dealer uh liquidity facility
untouched all of them untouched and
quite contrary to what some have
suggested this is no big rewrite
of the fed's 13-3 lending facilities
couldn't be
further from that what it is is an
acknowledgement
that the three programs we created in
march and which by the way
we put an expiration date on them in
march
we said they end on december 31st
but now we have folks on the other side
of the aisle who have a novel
interpretation of the statute
saying well they don't really have to
end or if they do end we could bring
them back to life
but we shouldn't even be having this
conversation
but but we are because we've got this
interpretation that we have to deal with
well my statute simply what my language
simply does
is it follows the statute and
calls for the the end of this how do we
do this there's three steps one is
we rescind the money that never got used
because as i said the markets
responded so quickly we never never
needed to use this money
and i think our democratic colleagues
agree on on this provision
the legislation my language that i'm
trying to uh get in this package
reiterates that these cares facilities
end on december 31st
as congress intended no no
you know i was in the room when we were
writing this bill nobody thought
that any of these programs are going to
last beyond the end of the year
but as i say because of this novel legal
interpretation
we need to reiterate in an unambiguous
way that they
end on december 31st as congress
intended and
finally we ensure that they can't be
simply restarted
next year or sometime thereafter or
duplicated
without congressional consent
now we have folks on the other side of
the aisle who are
raising all kinds of objections they're
very upset about this
and it's fair to ask why why would that
be
well certainly isn't because
the credit markets are back in turmoil
and they think we need to restore the
flow of private credit that would be
ridiculous the credit markets are
functioning
as well or better than they ever have
it's
not even not even a close call
so it's not that no what it is is
something very different mr chairman and
that is the problem that
some of my colleagues want to morph
these facilities
into a use that was never intended for
them
they want to convert them away from this
temporary emergency liquidity facilities
designed to stabilize markets and
restore the flow of credit to convert it
away from that
and instead to use them to
implement fiscal policy and maybe social
policy and certainly
to allocate credit based on their
political preferences
what what is one of the ways that um our
democratic colleagues would like to do
that one
they want to bail out irresponsible
states now look i get
that there are some states across the
union
that have suffered financially because
of covet there's other states that
haven't been harmed at all in fact
they've got more revenue coming in this
year than they had last year
it varies and there's definitely a
category of state and municipalities
that have suffered a loss of revenue and
we can and should have an ongoing debate
in this body about what to do about that
if anything
but that's our responsibility if we are
going to send money
to states and municipalities we should
have a bill
appropriate the funds and have a vote in
congress so that the american people can
hold us accountable see that's what
happens we get held accountable
and so when an action like that is done
through
legislation it's out in the open it's
transparent
it happens in the light of day and the
american people know who to hold
accountable
that's not what our democratic
colleagues want to do they want to force
the fed
to do this for them and how do we know
that
because they passed a bill called the
heroes act
h.r 6800 that
instructs the federal reserve to use the
municipal
facility for exactly this purpose
super long-term ultra-low cost loans to
municipalities
up to ten years at one quarter of one
percent
interest rates and states wouldn't even
have to attest
that they couldn't secure ordinary
credit they could just show up and get
it so
so the fed wouldn't be playing its role
its traditional role
as the lender of last resort in a
financial crisis it'd be the lender or
first resort
to their preferred constituency
there's the main street lending facility
if they could replicate that
who knows what kind of conditions they
would impose on
low-interest loans there whether it's
climate or other
policies that ought to be debated on
this floor
and ought to be determined through an
accountable process
so as i say none of this is speculative
our democratic colleagues have talked
about this they passed a bill that
actually does this
it's it's ironic that when we were
developing
the response to the financial cri to the
crisis of
of march of earlier this year some of
our colleagues
described this 500 billion dollar
fund that was intended to capitalize
these vehicles that would would lend
and restore liquidity they call it a
slush fund
one of many examples senator warren on
march 30th of 2020 said
the cares act created and i quote
a half trillion dollar slush fund that
trump administration could use
to help its political friends and punish
its political enemies
and i think that's a bad thing end quote
well now there's a new administration
and
now they want to keep the slush fund
mr president i ask unanimous consent to
complete my remarks before the vote
without objection thank you
so this is a very bad idea for many
reasons not the least of which
is to put the fed in this position of
being pressured
to make these these giveaway
transactions based on a political
pressure would completely politicize the
fed
it'd be the end of independence of the
and this is this is why this has never
been the role of
of our central bank the fed we've never
asked the fed to engage in fiscal policy
or promote social policy or to allocate
credit
based on political standing
that's guaranteed to politicize the fed
and undermine fed independence
fiscal and social policy is the rightful
realm
of the people who are accountable to the
american people and that's us that's
congress
i want to address another accusation
that's completely false and totally
unjustified and that is that somehow
this is an effort to hamstring the biden
administration
and prevent them from doing what they
want to do
let me assure you mr president my
colleagues my efforts to
ensure that this would be a temporary
facility
began when we began discussing the
it was in march that i was arguing
actually i i argued that we should have
this
end as soon as the financial markets
had restored their normal functioning
and no later than september 30th
i didn't win the argument we ended up
settling on december 31st
but that's when i started pushing to
have a
finite period of time in a short period
of time there was nobody in the room
who thought that this was supposed to go
on indefinitely
and once we started working on another
covid related bill
started in the summer time
and i became aware of this alternative
interpretation of the
language we put it in our bill and we
voted on that in september so this
language or the substantively similar
language has been
uh public for many many months now
i also want to stress that we're not
making
permanent changes to laws and congress
can always act again
the cures act already made these
facilities temporary they were supposed
to end at the end of the year
and of course no change in law is ever
permanent
any future congress can change it
back in march when this crisis hit the
fed and treasury
knew that they needed to come to
congress for the tools to solve it they
came to congress and we turned around
in an extraordinarily rapid fashion
these massive new facilities
that had never been imagined before we
responded quickly
and if there's some kind of future event
that calls for future set of
facilities of of this particular sort
they can come back to congress mr
president it's three facilities
three facilities that are
were launched in conjunction with the
cares act funded by the cares act
and i'm saying they've achieved their
purpose
they should come to an end they should
not be restarted
and a replica should not be created
that's all
some have suggested that the chairman of
the federal reserve
is has got some opinion on this i would
challenge anyone to find a statement in
the public record
that he has made in criticism of this
he's very well aware
of what's going on the last point i want
to make mr president
some on the other side have suggested
that our language is maybe too broad
and maybe it captures potential
facilities that shouldn't be captured
if if that is the sincere concern of my
colleagues on the other side i urge them
give me a call it's very easy to track
me down
if you've got an objection to the way
we've ordered this and you want a
language that is narrower i'm all heirs
we we could work this out
with that i yield the floor
all post-cloture time has expired
the question is on the deep's nomination
is there a sufficient second there
appears to be
the clerk will call the roll
mr alexander ms baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blump mr booker
mr bozeman mr braun
mr brown
so
you